hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game that was played in Denmark in
on the white end Moises who firstish and
he's up against Harry andreasen now this
is quite the unique game I'm not sure if
it falls more so under the educational
or entertaining category
feel free to share what your thoughts
are on it what I can say is that it's
rare for a game to not be entertaining
when you have this rare and aesthetic
tactic on board
we'll see that in the end game phase
also the opening itself one of the more
unique opening names you'll find in
chess Knight takes E4 signals this
Frankenstein Dracula variation out of
the Vienna game
in this game white continues with Queen
H5 looking straight for me on F7
Scholars mate like idea
if the Knight is captured we would have
this familiar Center fork trick this is
how black would get the piece back black
would already be doing very well with
this position
in our game is Queen H5
how to defend F7 Knight D6 Knights
defending Knight's also attacking
Bishop B3
black develops black defends E5
considered best is Bishop to E7 giving
back that pawn but this is also a line
now comes Knight B5 in Black
has to find an only move
the thread here is to take the Knight
with check and then give checkmate
G6 is the only move
Queen F3 white is persistent wants mate
on F7 just from a different angle
now in this game Knight F5 is played
F5 is also a move here and this line I
have to share with you this is
probably the line that pulls in
many players to this
variation of the Vienna because of the
craziness of it
it's the line I'm going to share with
you is one where black gives up a rook
and has compensation based on the better
developed pieces the strong knights in
the center strong Pawn presence
what does this look like exactly
well after Queen D5 black must now
defend F7 with the queen and allow this
Fork
and here's the compensation for black
the bishop comes to B7 and if White
isn't careful maybe the queen could even
be trapped after Knight D4 she's in the
center but she would be trapped
possible problems on G2
a messy game ahead to be sure
in our game
the Knight goes to F5 not the pawn
Queen D5 this queen is getting quite the
workout
first she's on H5 trying for mate then
F3 trying for mate and now here she is
on D5 yet again looking for me
on F7 only move here
Knight H6
D4 another instance where black is in an
only move situation
first it was the Knight trying to take
out the Knight on D6 and then give mate
enough seven and now it's the bishop
trying to knock the Knight out
only move is D6 the idea to meet the
move played in the game
Bishop takes Knight with the
in-betweener
Bishop E6
hitting the clean defending mate
Queen goes to F3 Bishop takes B3 Bishop
takes it on f8
and close to an only move here for black
has to choose between one of these two
has to counter attack the Knight
if
white or excuse me if black captures in
this position captures the bishop with
the King of The Rook
white would take the bishop we'd have
the Bishops exchange and white would
simply be up a knight
so black has to go after this guy
now comes Bishop to G7
and in this game The Rook goes to G8
considered best
is to capture the Knight now this line
I'm about to share with you is
interesting because it's another case
where
black can be giving up a rook and can
very easily be the side who's winning
this time giving up the king Rook
let's see this variation this is
considered best Bishop takes Knight
and if white takes the Rook after Knight
D4
says Queen F6 is the only move for white
all of a sudden
if you're more human you would see okay
my queen is hit and I should move the
queen and also defend against this Fork
well if you do that with let's say going
back home black would already be winning
black is down a rook but winning
why is that well there would be this
really powerful
deployment of the queen to G5 and what
would white do about this
there's no good answer to it
this seems like it defends but it
doesn't
after Queen F5 there's two threats there
would now be two threats two Fork
threats
Knight takes C2 with check
as well as Queen E4
two forks on board being threatened
black is winning with this variation
so this Rook doesn't necessarily have to
react to this threat
Bishop takes Knight is available in this
game though it's Rook G8
and from here Bishop F6 Queen D7
and in this game the Knight goes back to
A3 computer's a fan of Simply castling
giving the piece back and Blasting open
the center
white goes with Knight to A3
anticipating that this is going to hit
and at least it's there stopping the
fork on C2
Knight takes D4 follows Queen H3 Queens
are exchanged
and in this game Knight takes C2 is
played and from this point on white is
winning
considered best in the computer's eyes
is a line or one of the better moves is
to put this guy on the long diagonal
and play a position where white has a
knight versus blacks two Pawns
all right in this game Knight takes C2
is basically activating the white Rook
to get to this seventh rank we're not
really with this sequence simply
exchanging pawns exchanging C pawns but
it's almost as if white is winning a
pawn
uh the activity of a white Rook on the
seventh rank must be worth at least upon
all right in this game Bishop E4 follows
Knight G5
in this game Bishop takes G2 if Bishop
goes to C6 stopping The Rook from
getting here this Pawn can fall
this bishop remains a a big Thorn In
Black side
Bishop takes G2
and what do we do here
in the earlier variation when the white
Bishop was on G7 attacking The Rook The
Rook reacted went to G7 but white is not
going to be
doing similar in this game
white says go ahead take my Rook I want
to get to the seventh rank
Bishop takes Rook follows
Knight takes F7 watch how beautifully
these three pieces coordinate
these Rooks are doing nothing staring at
Pawns
from here Bishop D5 Knight D6 check only
move
Bishop G5 the king
needs a new Square
nearby there's this check a sad move
coming up rook h8 but at least the King
has a square
Bishop H6 check
only move
Rook G7 check King f8
this is this rare in aesthetic tactic I
spoke of at the start what we see in
action in this game
is a windmill tactic
Rook goes to C7 with check you could
also capture on B7 white doesn't go
straight in for this windmill
first inserts Knight to C8 it isn't
necessary but eventually we get on
course here with the windmill tactic
here we go with the check
here we go with a discover check white
picks up a pawn
King G8 What other options are there
if the King goes left
it would be a mate in two he has to keep
making use
or he has to keep going to f8 and G8
if you step on this Square here's the
main two
Knight D6 check
forcing King here
the Knight controls these two The Rook
has these three and nearby
mate with Bishop G5
so you have to keep going to G8
another check King f8 discover check
King G8 and now Rook takes Rook
Bishop takes Rook in one final move to
this game
there's only one way to win
Can you spot the final move
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go final move Knight D6
black resigns
why
you see what just happened
this last move has sealed
the black king
and rook in the corner
and there's no Escape
light has just taken away the F7 Square
from the King
the bishop has these two
what do you do
so this Knight in Bishop cannot be
disturbed by the Light Square bishop and
they forever control these three
these pawns could move right but we
would follow a general rule of Simply
taking towards the center there's no
problem here
what I have highlighted they all offset
what this position now comes down to
is a case where it is a white king and
two Pawns
versus a bishop
and the plan is to Simply come over here
on the queen side and start advancing
the pawns have the king assist in their
advance
you may have
one minor attempt by black to try for
stalemate but I don't believe there's
any way that black can force you to take
that light Square Bishop
the black king and Rook are forever
stuck
what I just shared with you
is a technique that good chess players
frequently use throughout a game
with this technique your taking what
appears to be complex
a uh a messy looking fraction for
instance
and you're trying to make it look simple
for it to be more easily understood
anyhow Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below I hope you enjoyed it
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
foreign